keep this Pawn tying down the black king  and the other Pawn will win the black  Bishop  game over wow Magnus just going through  the paces now  it's getting close to that  revenge for origin and Eric icy you must  be uh just fireworks inside him right  now it's getting so close  well it'll be a big relief for him  because he's had a couple of and Magnus  has had enough I think  um  he's had a couple of really really bad I  mean the match against Magnus he is so  upset angry with himself  no is he about to resign yeah yeah it's  it's done he's  he doesn't want any more but as I was  saying the final against Magnus was  quite an anti-climax I mean Arjun just  didn't get into gear and there it is  it's over Magnus Carlsen he loses to 19  year old Arjun Eric icy massive comeback  for the Young